please press the launch button oh [ __ ]
today I'm playing with this beautiful
beast the mclaren 570s the everyday
McLaren which I guess makes sense if
your everyday rich
back here is the engine it is a twin
turbo v8 putting out 562 horsepower that
is a crap ton of horsepower check out
these awesome doors little hidden button
flip them up to call dihedral doors
which is Latin for whoo here's one big
reason they call this the everyday
McLaren it's got a little bit of a
hatchback and back not a ton of space in
there to be honest but better than
nothing
supercars got to have cool buns McLaren
has cool buttons the powertrain one
that's where things get fun goes from
normal to sport to track that's like
kind of waking up then getting coffee
then do a little bit of crystal meth
true story this is the first McLaren
ever with a vanity mirror in the
flip-down shade that look good you're
gonna need some place to put your water
that's going to go back here in the one
cup holder super easy to get to just
pull it right back out again while
you're driving at high speeds
every other supercars with cheetah this
is a cheetah that lives in Brooklyn and
get some really nice wheat at night
keeps things a little bit more low-key
it's easy it's chill as with just about
every supercar in the world today can
get this one in a standard transmission
these days and automated transmission
can do everything faster there are these
great paddles right here where I can
control the gears if I don't want to I
don't have to
yo is this the new uber XXL this is yeah
exactly so this is the thing is like you
could have picked me up in an Acura TL
and I've been like CAD boom damn we made
it so we get other interior mm-hmm you
realize you know I'm not a car person at
all you're not a car person no not at
all
who's not a car person yeah I had to
take you up on this offer because very
rarely do I get to sit in a car like
this and I got to see what all the hype
is about okay so the fact that we're
super low yeah and I can feel the bumps
this is a part of the experience this is
a part this is exactly you're in it
you're a feeling life right now right
such an Indian father how fast does this
go this will top out at 204 miles per
hour yeah go vroom dude oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] so it does that like that yeah
farther and longer yeah yeah you can
imagine how that gets like that'll get
the blood surpass these guys oh [ __ ]
John you're about to bat pass like op
you really are like I find a magician
I'm in baseball that's incredible yeah
no this is it like we're doing a thing
that could end really badly but it's so
much fun how do you as a fan of this
remove the douchebag factor you go what
I'm saying no completely because yeah
you say you know what I'm just gonna do
me yeah sometimes for some guys it's a
lot of gold chains right in a really big
ugly watch people they're just being
authentically themselves you're being
authentically themselves I gotta get
some groceries my wife is gonna kill me
if I'd not come home okay with some
diapers and some toilet paper
they're super sorry I know you're busy
man no but do you mind if we just run in
against himself no I'd love to go to a
grocery store with suicide doors nailed
it
we're seriously gonna do this yeah I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna party right here
because I don't want anybody hitting my
car
all right we've officially become those
guys let's get some groceries
now I'm douchebag by association I have
no idea how all this stuff is gonna this
is the most random collection of food by
the way we got a fish head over here my
daughter likes fish heads sardines and
tomato sauce I believe this is kimchi
this right here this is a [ __ ] you size
of mayonnaise yeah all right we start
with the back we're gonna start with the
hatch see look at this all right
oh we're putting it in here yeah so you
throw those in I love how we're just
throwing [ __ ] in a McLaren like were in
the zombie apocalypse so we just like
need our supplies and we had to jet away
in a $200,000 car okay few more cans
nailed it but here's the best part
there's a Franck there's all the what as
a Franck there's a front trunk it
sounded like are you about to [ __ ] the
trunk I'm not saying I'm not going to
I'm about to [ __ ] it with that is that a
fire extinguisher that is a fire
extinguisher you know why cause it's a
race car you need to have a fire
extinguisher on a track but also I think
the kids would call this lit as
Budi the Millennials would call this lit
yeah I just I just feel like I just did
like a Hillary Clinton pander where I
was like no this is so lit yeah why
don't we whip it Nene our way back to
home base what else you got in there I
got some anchovy paste oh yeah I got
some jack mackerel water yeah please get
the mackerel in there I want that for
later okay yeah if we do crash this car
later yeah
uh it is gonna be the smelliest car
crash I think in New York history ever
yeah that's a lot for New York if you
think about it
ah ha I love how we just did the yeah we
won McLaren yeah exactly that's great
every name of clearin man minor issue
reddit what we still got more yeah
one last thing man if you don't mind oh
god the cat litter I'm sorry oh come on
I have a lot of cash on I'm sorry
you're good yeah closing the door watch
your hands yeah I'm doing great look how
comfortable this ride is seriously I
really appreciate this I know you're a
busy man
you probably have to get to work soon
yeah man The Daily Show literally thinks
I'm at a dentist's appointment well
we'll get you to work let's do this all
right I just got to stop and drop these
things off first okay okay let's sir all
right
people are looking at us ah oh I
literally just closed my finger in the
door that hurt that's Karma right there